[Music]
jennifer lopez has done it again
literally recreating her 2001 music
video
for love don't cost a thing 20 years
later
[Music]
the 51 year old singer showed she still
got the jlo glow
in the new version which she shared on
instagram
but one thing has changed yes
that's a t-shirt with a vintage photo of
herself on it
which is kind of the ultimate flex
jen captioned the video quote happy 20th
anniversary to my second album jlo
had a little fun at a recent shoot
[Music]
love don't cost a thing was the first
single of jennifer's second album jlo
which was released on january 16th in
2001.
oh he has her to show my necklace
and e.t was with her as she made history
becoming the first person to have a
movie and album
debut at number one at the same time
it's funny i guess
in a few years i'll look back and i'll
go that was the
best thing that ever happened to me in
my whole life
you know but right now i just like i'm
back at work and it just seems like
another day you know
[Music]
stuff like that happens and you're like
you know
do you know do you know that you made
history yesterday i'm like
it just doesn't sink in because you're
just a person so it's weird
but j-lo's latest throwback isn't the
first time she's revisited
one of her iconic looks who could forget
her green dress
at the 2000 grammys versace i saw
donatello with it and i had to have it
for the grammy
she hit the runway in milan wearing an
updated version of the look in 2019
jennifer opened up to et in november
about passing along confidence
to her daughter emmy but what do you
think that
emmy would say like is your beauty
wisdom that you've given to
her you know i think it's about at the
end of the day
beauty starts from the inside out and i
always i always tell her that
um you can be youthful and timeless at
every age it's it's how you feel about
yourself on the inside so that self-love
and and beauty company being about
self-care
as well as is a form of self-love you
know when you go into the mirror
and you kind of you know wash that face
and
wash things away and you just take time
and you take your little rollers and you
know i don't know if you use those
things but
i miss my whole routine you know when we
launch
and i'll show you the things that i do
um but when you do that it's kind of
like letting the bad thoughts go away
it's kind of like
just kind of taking a moment for
yourself to say you know i'm taking care
of you
i'm gonna be your little keeper right
now and we're gonna we're gonna get
ready for the day and we're gonna
we're gonna have an amazing day and
you're amazing and i think those things
are the things i try to teach
my my girls is like you have to feel
great about yourself
first so then you can be great for
everybody else